all right guys bang-bang I've got a very
special guest today Anna is going to
walk us through why we all don't know
how to learn and what we can do about it
so thanks so much for for doing this of
course thank you for having me that's
that's a good way to put it what we're
learning what we're not absolutely all
right let's just start with your
background you spent a long time
teaching you went to a bunch of
different schools I just walk us through
where were you born and how do we get to
you being a teacher initially yeah so um
I'm from Panama but because of my dad's
job he worked at a multinational
corporation so we moved around a lot so
I was born in Panama but after a month
we moved to Colombia then we moved to
Venezuela then we moved to India then we
moved to Mexico then to Brazil then back
to Panama and then I studied in the US
so really I went to you know I I moved
around as a kid and by the time I was
fifteen I had been to ten different
schools because I also went to different
schools in the different countries that
I went to and I guess that a lot of my
ideas about education and all my
questions come from my experience um
having attended ten different schools
and how you know I didn't really see
that many differences in all the
different schools that I went to even
though they were all you know once
somewhere nondenominational some were
really religious somewhere more
traditional some were more progressive
some where America and the other ones
where national and still learning look
the same so that's what kind of like I
started thinking about this and then I
decided to become a teacher I loved
working with kids and that also was when
I started to see what was happening in
schools and how it wasn't really working
and finally last year I decided to leave
in order to explore different
alternatives and kind of raise questions
that get more people to think about how
little learning is happening in the
traditional schools got it and so when
you started teaching what grade were you
teaching and kind of what does that look
like from the teachers seat most people
listening have never been a teacher
they've just been in the student aspect
of that relationship but what does that
look like
right so I when I decided to study
education I went to NYU and I did
childhood education and special
education as my undergraduate and one of
the things that I think is really
valuable about teacher training is that
they make you student teach a certain
amount of hours I can't remember right
now but it was a lot like for two years
I was in five different schools just
observing
you know the whole teacher-student
interaction and what it looks like and
that you know I was in multiple grades I
studied elementary school so I was in
first second third fourth fifth sixth as
a student teacher and really that's
where most of my learning came from from
observing mostly the kids and and how
they were learning and how they were not
learning and then when I got my first
teaching job it was in Boston my husband
was doing his MBA and I was just
teaching at a small school a small
private school in Boston and I talked
first in third grade in that school and
then I moved to Panama and I started
working and that's where I worked for
four years at a big American school and
I taught third and fourth grade so
really my age group the one that I enjoy
working with the most are like 9 and 10
year olds and I like that age because
they're not too young so they you know
they're kind of like ant but they're
still not too cool for school so it was
like the perfect age and I enjoyed it a
lot okay so this is a weird question
but like why is learning import right so
you spent a bunch of your time thinking
about how we learn and what we learn and
what the structures are everything but
just like the core question of like why
is learning important especially at a
young age but even as we get to be
adults they said how do you think about
it's interesting that you ask that
because that's what kids ask when
they're in school they're like why why
do we even have to learn and and that's
when you start to notice oh my gosh like
we're doing things wrong because if a
kid is asking you why do we need to
learn it's because they're not seeing
the benefits of learning and and that's
one of the big issues here that in
schools learning has been kind of like
removed from students and it's it's
something like imparted by a teacher and
something that happens inside this
structure so I think it's really
interesting that to me learning is
really what happens outside of school
and it's super important because that's
what that's when you start to see kids
intro
and and what kind of things they're
inclined to and and what are the kind of
things that they could end up doing in
the future
so Tunis is not really like about what
what we're teaching them and what
they're learning but more about like if
they're learning right and and
unfortunately what I noticed in schools
is that there's very little learning
because they don't even they see it very
detached from them and and once you
start to give them this space and the
time to actually you know take charge of
their learning then it's completely the
process is completely different you see
kids motivated wanting to come back and
then going through tangents and creating
things that you wouldn't have even
thought that an eight-year-old could do
or a nine-year-old could do right and
that to me is really learning and and
once they keep coming back for more then
that's when it's really important like
that's when things are going well so the
reason why I wanted to record this
episode is Paul Graham recently wrote an
essay all about like learning to unlearn
that he basically highlighted saying hey
every single person that I talk to
pretty much learned how to memorize and
kind of beat the test but they actually
learned to actually learn and so I said
look let's go talk to somebody who is
literally an expert at why is that so
maybe you can start out just let's
highlight the issues that kind of the
traditional schooling system and the
current mechanisms like why are we all
built to learn the way that we do learn
through that school system what are
those issues yeah so so the thing is
that traditional school as we know it
and dislike compulsory like compulsive
schooling was something that was created
100 20 years ago and for a very
different purpose in a very different
time so back then it was important to
train kids to become assembly line
workers for you know we were seeing just
a revolution so they had to work at
factories we also had to train kids to
be in the military so kids had to learn
specific set of things and they had to
learn how to follow instructions in for
the jobs that they were going to have
back then the problem so it worked back
then the problem is that the years
started to pass and pass all the other
industries started changing
you know us as expected except for
education so you know if you look at a
picture of a classroom and the way
things were done 120 years ago and you
look at a picture now you're gonna see
basically the same thing maybe you'll
see more technology you know here and
there but we leave the the structure and
the way that we are teaching in
traditional schools hasn't changed and
the problem with that is that nowadays
we need kids that are creative we need
entrepreneurs we need kids that are
willing to carve their own paths and
figure things out without instructions
yet in school we're still training them
to be assembly line workers you know to
operate under instructions like kids
barely know what to do if a teacher
doesn't tell them like this is what you
need to do now we are still having kids
you know comply to rules and be obedient
and the whole nature of a school right
now it just goes against everything we
know about how kids learn right so if
you think about school you can't really
talk you know teachers tell you all the
time like you're not here to socialize
you're here to learn so you know the
instinct of a kid is to talk so they go
to school they can't talk the instinct
of a kid they're so active they need to
be moving in school you need to be
sitting down for eight hours you know
except when you go to recess and there's
plenty of evidence showing how you know
all the ill effects of sitting down for
so long in school you know they have to
be listening to a teacher and listening
to a lecture like that's not how kids
learn kids need to be active and
creating things and making mistakes and
trying things out so all these things go
against the nature of a kid and against
how kids learn yet we continue to do it
just because the system hasn't changed
in so many years and many people don't
even question this just because it's the
way that we you know we were all in the
system and and that's just the way it is
and many people are scared to raise
questions and to kind of like try
something different many people are like
well what I can't play with my kids
education like what if I try something
different and they don't end up learning
I'm like they're not learning right now
so really it's about exploring something
different so so that's the main issue if
you ask me that we're still training
kids for jobs that don't exist and a
stat that I saw the other day that was
just very alarming is that two-thirds of
the
kids that are in elementary school right
now we'll end up do jobs that haven't
been created so really we are teaching
them for a future that doesn't exist yet
so instead of focusing on teaching from
a curriculum that may or may not be
relevant we should be teaching them how
to learn on their own and how to figure
things out and how to create things
right because that's probably what
they're gonna end up doing so I think
it's Neil deGrasse Tyson who he's got
this story that he tells and I'm getting
the second hand from plaintiff so
forgive me if I mess it up but basically
he tells the story of he's walking
behind a mother and her son and they're
on the road and there's a big puddle and
as they're walking by the little kid
naturally kind of goes towards it and
he's about to make this big leap but
he's gonna jump right in the puddle and
the water's gonna go everywhere and all
stuff and the parent basically pulls the
kid away from it right and his whole
thing was like look the kid wants to go
figure it out like the kid has to learn
when I step in it the water shoots out
it gets me wet like there's all of these
things that happen but then there's also
the parent being like I don't want to
clean it up I don't want to deal with
this and whatever and so it feels almost
like to your point like there's this
element of conditioning kids to not be
kids to some degree and so my question
to you then is like why was the system
structured that way
in the beginning right so it hasn't
changed but when the system was
originally built like why was it so
lecture based and and kind of built the
way it was is it a control thing is it
just like they didn't know any better
like what do you think they're yeah well
well they didn't they didn't need for
people to come up with you know to be
creative and to come up with ideas like
that was not the purpose the purpose was
for kids to follow instructions and for
that they had to be very rigid and they
had to like kind of have this
authoritative role so that kids would
comply and that was the whole purpose
and and it worked really well like you
had all these kids you know the teachers
the founder the fountain of wisdom and
the one that tells you what to do and
this and that and and it worked back
then for those jobs but now I find it so
interesting like kids all right they get
in trouble they question something you
know if any
they do it in a respectful way like
teachers still have this not all but
many teachers still have this notion
that they are the authority and anyone
who challenges Authority like it's wrong
and I'm like I did it very differently
in my class I was always like you guys
question everything if something doesn't
make sense like respectfully you can
raise your hand and say you know what I
don't agree with that or I don't you
know I I want to dig more into this or I
you know have a different opinion um and
and we need more of that
but but that's the big no-no in school
right it's not part of the obedience and
and and compliance kind of like culture
in a school which is really damaging for
the kind of people that we want you know
to raise so the other thing and I don't
have young kids right so I'm not as
well-versed on this but it feels like
there's the structure of the school is
very driven on obedience and like sit in
your seat be quiet we're gonna tell you
everything you're describing the other
thing is it seems like also there's been
this explosion Express in the United
States of ADHD prescriptions it's kind
of like we're also gonna just drug the
kids into behaving to some degree and
you know pretty much have you talked to
anyone over the age of like 35 like we
all had ADHD like by today's standard
like we all had ADHD
and but we didn't get drugged and so
maybe like what did you see in the
classroom and what do you see now with
which is that aspect of trying to
control kids um I don't even know if I
can talk about this but I'm just going
to if I had actually you know paid
attention to the psychologists and their
parents that would come to me and be
like my kid definitely has ADHD like we
need to prescribe him right and the
teacher kind of has to say and I was
always like no like how I said yes to
most up and I'm telling you I taught in
this past for like four years the amount
of times that I had a meeting to discuss
if we should put the kid in medication
and it was really my saying cuz the
teachers the one I would have had like
ten kids in medication for ADHD and to
be perfectly on it yes they were
extremely active but in my mind that is
normal I don't know if it's because I
was like that and I got prescribed
ritalin the entire thing because I
couldn't stop talking I couldn't stop
moving to me that is normal and if you
walked into my class something like
interesting was that you would have kids
I don't know who I was talking about
this to this but you would have kids
like reading standing up or you and and
it's because I be they would ask me like
can I stand up and read I'm like sure
like if that works for you go ahead like
I don't care if you're sitting down or
not like like that doesn't make sense to
me like some kids were on the rug as
long as they were doing what they were
supposed to it doesn't matter you know
we would have frequent breaks where we
were moving because I know how important
it is for kids to move I am the kind of
person that when I need to be creative
and when I need to come up with things I
need to go on a walk I cannot sit in
front of my computer so I cannot expect
that from kids who are even more active
than adults right so to me that is just
so messed up it's so messed up that that
when you walk into a classroom you're
like oh what such a well-behaved room
all the kids are sitting down like this
to me I'm like oh my gosh poor kids
there's very little learning going on in
here
you know yeah it's so I guess like well
you're a kid right when you're nine ten
years old like you can yell and scream
and complain whatever but like if your
parents say take the medicine you take
the medicine if your teacher says sit
down and shut up and listen like you
pretty much do it you may fight it you
may be good at fighting it but
ultimately you succumb to the authority
because you want to ride home you want
to eat dinner like you know you don't
want to get spanked or I guess and you
can't do that these days right but like
all of those things so that still
persists though as you get older as well
to a degree where it almost feels like
there's this world of people saying like
I want to learn but it's supposed to be
painful I need to sit and like study
this book and read from you know front
to back I'm like that's the only way to
learn and so is it a thing where like
adults are just much easier to like kind
of suck up the pain and that they just
do what they have to do or is it to
worry that we're conditions since we're
so young that that is the past and that
is the only path I really think that
it's that we've been conditioned to
believe that and and I'm glad you bring
that up because I can give you examples
of how I saw the complete opposite in my
room so one of the things I really
believe and I talk about a lot is that
you cannot enforce learning like you can
it doesn't matter how hard you try you
cannot force somebody to learn
what you can do and not a lot of people
take this approach but I did and it
worked is you can inspire kids to want
to learn so we leave and we can talk
about how the role of the teacher has
changed throughout the years but the
most effective teachers are those who do
a good job selling the idea of learning
you know you kind of make kids be like I
really want to learn about that that
looks interesting you know you make it
like for them to be curious about it and
want to come because if you try the
other approach they are gonna repel it
nobody likes to be told what to do right
especially when it comes to like
learning so one thing that worked really
well for me is that I've never used
rewards in my classroom or like a
behavior chart and this is really common
for teachers and I don't blame them I
mean once when you're in a room for
seven hours a day with 24 kids different
personality I mean it's chaos like it
really is chaos and then you have the
set appearance of each kid which is even
more chaos right so I don't blame
teachers for thinking oh I'm gonna go
and have the behavior chart and you know
pump every time you misbehave that's one
point in this mad here's what I've
noticed that doesn't work like it may
work in this short-term the kid may
learn okay I'm not gonna talk right now
but the moment the kid has a chance to
talk the kid will do it and the
relationship that you're establishing
with the kid is a really negative one
they see you as the enemy and they don't
want to do anything that you're telling
them in you know like learning so what
really worked for me is I would give
them lots of choices and together we
would come up with the things that we
thought that were appropriate in the
classroom the things that weren't and I
would always tell them like I trust you
until you give me a reason not to and we
established a culture where kids didn't
feel like I had to control where the
classroom and the rules and because of
that I had very very little behavior
issues in my room and every time the
principal would walk by our teachers
would walk by they're like what to get
these kids I'm like I give them choice
and I trust them and we've established
you know a relationship where I'm not
like the authoritative figure I'm like I
don't want to say a friend because I
wasn't a friend but you know I was
someone that they I was approachable and
they saw that my intentions were for
them to learn and that works really well
and for parents as well like you know
establishing that the behavior problems
just really diminish it feels like I
wasn't the best behaved kid even all the
way through high school
and I remember you'd walk in certain
rooms and the teachers who wanted to be
more authoritative like you're like
literally what can I get away with in
here how far can we push the teacher
right and even when you're literally
like a teenage boy you feel the same way
and it's even worse when you're younger
but then there were teachers have been
literally on day one like hey here's the
deal
we don't have behavior issues in here
because I trust you you trust me like
we're just gonna work together and
you're gonna walk out of here learning
things I'm gonna learn things from you
like we're cool and it's almost like
this mutual respect to some degree and
that I think people kind of get used to
that me when they get older into college
and stuff but it sounds like you were
able to take some of those same
mechanisms and bring it all the way down
to kids as young as you know nine ten
years old and had the same impact yeah
and then just being really honest with
them like I cannot even tell you the
amount of times that kids were like so
why are we learning this and I'm like I
have no idea because I've never used
this in my entire life and sometimes I
would be like let's forget about this
let's try something else like obviously
I had you know the to a certain extent
cuz I did have to follow a curriculum
but I was like you know don't if they
have a question and they don't
understand something and you can just be
honest with them like you need this for
this and when you explain it and they
see the relevance then they start to
understand I remember had this kid who
was like they had to learn and memorize
like all the states in the US and this
kids like miss fab like I I've never
been to the US I don't know what I'm
gonna be I live in Panama like I don't
want to learn the stays I want to learn
the provinces of Panama wouldn't that be
more relevant and I'm like you're
totally right like you're totally right
like why am I gonna force you to learn
the states in the u.s. you're right you
know so it's when they see that you have
this approach and you know another
answer could have been like no because
you have to and I'm the teacher and you
know what you don't get to question this
like this is what you're learning you
can expect that they're not going to
learn at all so and it's it's like
really using your common sense and
thinking about what you would have
wanted as a kid in order to be find
learning appealing right yeah so we talk
a lot about like the structure of
learning right
but what kids are learning and I think
we kind of what you're getting at here
is there's this toxic school culture
that you've talked about before which
essentially it's just um as the teachers
are going to regurgitate all this
information you're going to do your best
to retain it
brain for a finite amount of time the
test is next Friday don't forget it
between now and Friday but on Saturday
you don't have to remember anything like
you passed the test you're good
move on and it almost feels like we kind
of wasted between now and Friday
memorizing something that you literally
will never use or retain that
information so let me talk a little bit
about this like toxic school culture and
kind of how you see those issues today
yeah so I I find it in there's like a
lot to unpack here but I find it really
interesting that when people cuz it's I
mean at this point everyone knows that
that to a certain extent that there's
very little learning going on and the
kids are not remembering things and the
kids are not retaining and kids that
want to go to school and they don't like
learning or school people know this but
the reaction of like those policymakers
and the people who do the curriculum and
this and that is okay kids are not
learning
okay let's you know we need to raise the
bar and we need to add more homework and
let's make the school day longer and
let's you know just more regular more
rigor more assessments let's test them
and I'm like what like how did we get to
this conclusion like that's not the
problem is not lack of rigor the problem
is that kids don't care and they don't
have to because of the way that we're
doing things right and if a kid doesn't
care it doesn't matter how many
standards and how many tests and how
much you try to drill information
they're not going to learn so since you
know you know that was the approach and
since the No Child Left Behind policy
was put in place like we've had this
obsession with like metrics and
measuring learning and and standards and
high stake testing and to me that has
made everything absolutely worse you
know just the environment in the school
when it's time for this you know
high-stakes testing is just insane like
like if anyone actually saw the inside
of a school they would be like this is
not humane not for the teachers not for
the students not for the parents like
the whole thing is messed up and it's
exactly what you said you see teachers
quickly trying to like cram all the
information before you do this big test
like kids are stressed out there's
anxiety all over the place and then
right after the test kids don't recall a
thing so it's like we just wasted all
this time like prepping for a test and
and you know getting kids telling kids
quote unquote
this is a high-stake test like this is
really important like your you know
school experience depends on this kids
how are they gonna perform well with all
this pressure right and I've realized
many things that it is one that the
grades don't really tell us much like
you can have kids that do really well in
a test because they figure it out the
way to do well and they've learned
nothing and then you have kids who
actually know the material and you know
from having conversations with them and
from seeing what they've accomplished
but then do really poorly on the test
cuz there's not good test takers I took
the SAT three times and oh my gosh thank
God I never thought like Anna you're
dumb no I just I always knew like I'm
just not a contestant here like this
whole thing doesn't work for me um so I
just think it's like to be just
perfectly blunt here like our priorities
are all messed up you know like like all
this like when you remove all that
testing and all that you know like
standards and all this then that's when
you have more opportunity to start to
see learning happening right and there's
I have a story with this so my first two
years I did exactly you know what I had
to do right I would teach from the
curriculum I would deviate often to be
honest like I was never that teacher
that taught everything from the
curriculum but the kids were happy the
kids were learning parents were really
happy so it was working but then by the
third year I was like I'm done like I
can't keep you know from day one
prepping kids for this test like we just
know this is not fun like I just don't
see any relevance so the third year I
decided to rebel and I was like I'm
gonna do things my way I'm gonna pull
things from Pinterest I'm gonna just you
know if I see a unit that kids are not
gonna use I'm gonna just skip it and
teach kids things that are not even in
the curriculum like personal finances
you know things like that you know and I
was with another teacher that had the
same mentality so we were able to do
this together and it was awesome but
then it came time towards the end of the
year for the big test right so in my
school we did something called the map
test and it's this it's a standardized
test that kids do in math reading and
writing so they take it at the beginning
of the year and they score a percentage
and then the program gives you like a
projected growth that the kid needs to
meet by the end of the year what's
interesting is that the teachers
evaluations are tied to student
performance so if your class doesn't
perform
well or the kids you know the percentage
of kids just don't meet that target of
growth then you know you can get fired
like it's it's your job right your job
is in the line so it was kind of you
know risky move that I was like I'm just
not gonna teach these things and then
when the time for the test came I was
like I'm not gonna do test prep like I
haven't been teaching these things
throughout the entire year I'm not gonna
like mortify my kids for two weeks doing
test prep like let's just see what
happens time of the test comes the kids
take the test and when I go in for my
end-of-the-year evaluation the principal
I was like I didn't even know what to
expect I was like oh my gosh but I kind
of knew that I was gonna leave the
school soon so I was like oh well and
then the principal was like well she cuz
kids from kindergarten all the way to
12th grade take this test and she was
like Ana
you're your class scored the highest in
your third-grade class in reading and
math so in two of the three categories
out of the entire school and I'm like
wait what do you mean she's like well
your kids most of you kids like 90% of
you kids either met or exceeded their
targeted growth so you know please tell
me how how did you do this test prep and
I'm like do you want to know the truth
actually this is the first year that I
decided not to follow the curriculum you
know like to the you know the way I
usually do and I did not do any test
prep and I didn't even like mortify the
kids they just went in and and they did
clearly really well so this tells you
that it doesn't really like the like
cramming and teaching for a test won't
necessarily you know provide good
results right my kids were learning
plenty in different ways and they were
able to do well in the test even better
than previous years so that's just an
example of that it almost feels like
there's a lot of studies now at this
point about like kids who are more
well-rounded whether it's in sports in
school whatever rather than say to kids
like hey you're gonna be a doctor at age
two right and like every single thing
you do in your academic career is geared
towards you being a doctor like they
actually end up not performing as well
as doctors than the kid who most of
their career learned all of these
different skills right was interested in
a bunch of different things kind of
explored it all ends up being the doctor
but they're just pulling from a much
more like fast information like database
it sounds like that's kind of what
kids were doing right is that were more
well-rounded going into this rather than
just trying to optimize for how do I get
all the right answers on this test that
well-roundedness ends up being a greater
advantage yeah so absolutely we were
doing things that were more related to
the real world right so they were
learning actually because they could see
the relevance and I was not teaching
this skills which is what was really
interesting but then he goes with what I
believe right like that was a perfect
example like I wasn't teaching this hard
core skills we were doing projects we
were going outside we were exploring the
things that they were telling you that
they were interested in and the skills
just kind of like come along which is
really interesting right like there's
like you don't need to explicitly teach
many of the things that we do in school
right so here's what I've noticed when a
kid is interested in something and the
kid wants to learn about something they
will figure it out especially now with
computers like that you will see them
like oh my god I need to figure this out
they would go to the computer figure out
all the facts then they would come the
next and they're like I read the entire
history of World War two and I was like
whoa okay I didn't even ask you to do
that but you sure that's great so when
the kids are interested and and they
want something they will figure it out
that's what I've noticed so ironically
by like stepping back and kind of like
open it up and leaving it to them that's
more productive and kids will actually
get more done than if we try to
intervene and tell them exactly what to
do and how to do it I my favorite videos
on the Internet is a I think it's a mom
and she's sitting in her kitchen and
she's like recording her what looks like
made five six-year-old son around the
corner he's at the dinner table and he's
doing his homework and all of a sudden
he says Alexa 2+2 unless it says back 4
right and and of course everyone the
Internet's like you can't do that right
do you get ever like freaking out and
I'm like that's the smartest kid in the
class like I hope that that is hilarious
I love that I love that that's when kids
would be like me stop I need to look up
this word what do I have to use the
dictionary I'm like no like no please
use the computer and they're like oh
because my previous teachers would tell
me how to use the dictionary I'm like
know who carries around a dictionary now
I can have a phone in your pocket you're
gonna look this things up don't use a
dictionary unless you want to but no you
know you just you need to embrace the
fact that kids have all these tools to
their disposal and this is a little bit
of a threat to teachers because this
means that teachers no longer have to be
you know their role is no longer to
deliver information right especially
with when this information is available
online like the role of the teacher
really now is to be a facilitator and to
provide you know the space and the
conditions for kids to create things
right and to be a source of motivation
really that's the role of the teacher
nowadays but it's really difficult to
make this transition and teachers still
want to just you know be the ones in
charge of everything the problem is that
when you do that the kids are just not
learning because you're removing the
learning from them right the more space
and the more Liberty you give them then
the more learning is going to happen so
one of the things I love that you talk
about is like how do we raise kids to be
creators entrepreneurs producers like
things or people who can create things
right and so like what is that solution
we talk about the problems but like what
is the solution or what does that design
look like for how kids can learn yeah so
again in school a lot of what kids are
doing for 12 years like that's a long
time is they are again following
instructions and really like working
through this worksheets and like
make-believe projects and things that
are just real in the school environment
it's like that's the reality like very
rarely do you see kids actually going
out and solving a problem in the real
world or things that are relevant right
so it's interesting because to me a good
education is one that where kids leave
or they graduate you know being
extremely aware of what they're good at
having had plenty of experience creating
and building different things on failing
and then trying again and getting
feedback until they nail something and
then you know and having that desire to
keep learning and those three things are
not happening right now and the one that
the one that we're talking about right
now is like how do you get more kids to
create well giving them the opportunity
to create things so I recently like sent
out a tweet storm with David of
my Combinator and how you know I just
find it fascinating that model cuz
that's how kind of like how I envisioned
kids you know a school nowadays right if
you want to call it a school but a place
where you know kids go and they're
putting two teams depending on what
they're interested in they have this
idea as they balance of ideas and they
just start building things and then
every two weeks they have checkpoints
and they get feedback and then you know
they see what works they test it and
then they build again and and you know
they need more opportunities to do these
things and just build and create and
create and we don't give them that space
in school in school they're sitting down
learning from a curriculum so I'm really
interesting in creating that space and
and you know before kovat happened like
I was already thinking about doing it in
the online space just so that kids from
different countries could just join and
then it's a space for kids to create
different things they come in with a
problem that they want to solve and I
help them and I provide them with the
resources so that they can work it
through and come up with a prototype and
solve a problem that they're interested
in a real problem and I feel like I've
seen how through that process they're
learning so many so many things they're
learning how to do research how to like
talk about their ideas how to
incorporate feedback and change things
and to me that is the kind of learning
that is gonna be more valuable for kids
in the future right forget about what's
going on in school we've already talked
about how that's like they're not
preparing kids for the future
but if we open more centers or you know
creative studios or like I'm doing
online spaces for kids to just go in and
execute their ideas and try them out two
things are gonna happen one we I do feel
like we're gonna have more kids that are
fifteen sixteen like with their own
companies or with their own products out
there because they're gonna have tried
so many times and I don't have you seen
a kid when they're into something they
won't stop until they get to what they
want to so it's a matter of providing
them to space and the resources to
create and create and create and create
and and that's kind of like a makerspace
right for kids so that's kind of what
I'm envisioning that kids need more
nowadays and hopefully more people start
doing things like this so one of the
things I've always been fascinated by is
I think a disproportionate amount of
CEOs and founders of very large tech
companies as kids when tomorrow
schools and I am definitely not an
expert on these Montessori schools but
my understanding is that it's very much
less rigid it's more kind of this group
project based type learning it's a
little bit self-directed by the kids
what are you interested what are you not
interested and also one of the most
fascinating person I was reading about
is like the way that they address the
students right so your students we're
calling you miss fab like they would
just use first names right and it almost
treat the adult as a peer in some way I
think a lot of you would get scared by
that knowing oh my god how could you
ever you know kind of break down the
hierarchical structure but also it looks
like it works like there's a certain
type of person that comes out the other
end of that process and so it almost
feels like what you're talking about is
taking that type of more free-flowing
less rigid structure but focusing it
specifically on like creation right like
how do you build how do you build is
that a fair kind of assessment yeah yeah
absolutely so so I'm a big fan of
Montessori schools and you know there
are other kind of approaches that are
similar that are very student-centered
and that the kid is doing most of the
learning like Roger Amelia you have wall
d'oeuvres so there are I'm a big fan and
that's actually where I'm pulling you
know many of my ideas from because it's
around this idea that we want the kid to
learn so what can we do for the kid to
want to learn and I feel like it's you
know it's a lot more fun kids enjoy
going to this kinds of schools a lot
more what I fear though is and which is
one of the reasons why I'm trying the
online space is that the most privileged
kids are really the ones who get access
to this kind of educational experiences
right and this experiments that are
going on and the ones that are the least
advantage are the ones who kind of like
get stuck in the system and and that's
something that's constantly in my mind I
obviously don't have an answer for that
but one of the things that I was
thinking is well I believe that you know
more and more people are gonna have
access to an internet connection in the
future right like it's just becoming
more and more common even in remote
areas and of course this is not to say
everyone but I feel like I'm really
interested in exploring the online space
because I have a feeling that we can
recreate this Montessori approached
learning experiences in the online space
and have access to more kids
right and two kids that you know may not
have a Montessori School clothes
wherever they live but definitely I
think their mind is in the right place
and and I'm a big fan of all you know
all these experiments that are have been
done around that space and help me
understand how online education with
like young kids works right so kind of
two data points or watch your friends
who have young kids that are in kind of
early elementary years and all I keep
hearing is like there's no way that my
kid can sit in front of this computer
and zoom all day like there's not gonna
do it they already have a hard time
sitting in class let alone on my couch
where there's a TV and you know also
there's stuff going on then the second
thing is it also feels like part of the
value for young kids going to elementary
school is like the interaction with the
teacher right the teacher can be very
kind of hands-on with the kids etc so
the little it feels like that gets lost
online so how do you just think about
like online education and children yeah
so there's a there's an important
distinction to make here when it comes
to online education and online education
when done right it works beautifully and
it is not what we're seeing right now
that schools are doing right obviously
because of kovat like from one day to
the other like teachers and schools have
just had to like improvise and
transition to teaching virtually but to
me that's not online learning that is
remote online learning which is very
different and I'll tell you why when you
structure a course that you want to
teach online you do it with the frame of
mind you know you keep in mind your
virtual audience and you you're not
trying to recreate traditional schools
in the online space that's what we are
seeing because of kovat and that's what
I call remote learning but when online
learning is done right you designed the
entire course and the entire experience
with the virtual audience in mind and
you use the technologies and you do this
and you structure it very differently
and I'll give you some examples of
people that are doing it really right
and that I've seen how well it works but
what we're seeing commonly and what
you're saying that your friends are
telling you that if I were a kid I don't
even know what
would have done because I I cannot sit
in front of a computer the entire day No
is that schools are just trying to
recreate what they've always been doing
online right so so that definitely
doesn't work like we're talking about
how that didn't work in brick-and-mortar
school when kids are like sitting in
front of a teacher what do you think is
going to happen when you put them in
front of the screen like most of my best
friends are all teachers and I still
keep in touch with them all the ones
that worked out in my previous school
and it's just crazy to read that chat
because the poor you know teachers are
like trying to manage six hours a day of
back-to-back online classes obviously by
the third hour you get a group of kids
that are up to zoomed-out like they
don't want they don't want to pay
attention they're like first second
graders like what like that makes no
sense right so the whole point of online
learning is to concise the time so that
kids are not in school for seven hours
like kids don't need to be in school for
seven hours they probably still are
because it works like a daycare system
at this point
but really like kids online should be
just having direct instruction one hour
one and a half hours and then the rest
of the ten that should be learning in
unstructured ways and have time to go
out and socialize with other kids and go
to music class and sports and this and
that the problem is that we haven't
gotten to that point yet especially
because everything has happened so
quickly so two really good examples that
open my eyes to what a real good online
course is well David Carell who I know
you know he started this online course
called rite of passage and I also work
with Thiago Forte who has this thing
called fort labs and he fort elapsed and
he teaches building a second brain which
is a Productivity cost but also with
this like approach to online education
and I think that it works really well
because none of them were educators
before and so they need not have this
preconceived you know notions of what a
lesson should look like and how to
structure this you know for a
traditional face-to-face environment
they just sat down and they said okay we
want to create a course that's really
engaging that's gonna be online with a
virtual audience in mind how can we make
it different so they haven't prepped
something and put it online they just
created a whole new way to teach online
and it's structured very differently
from what a course in person would be
and it works incredibly like I am
impressed with how many
people want to come back with the weight
like how everyone's learning and and
it's incredible so this really ties with
this idea that I don't feel like like
like there's no way to fix schools like
I really don't think I think that we
just have to like rethink the whole
thing with you know what what are our
priorities right now what do kids need
to know nowadays what are the kind of
jobs that kids are gonna have in the
future what technologies do we have
available that we can use and then using
all that come up with a new way to teach
and learn and that can be done online
but it's not what we're seeing right now
what we're seeing right right now is
outrageous which is what you're saying
like having kids sitting in front of a
computer I am concerned I don't even
know what's gonna happen how much of
this do you think is for those online
courses that they're teaching like the
students are older right meaning that
they're just adults and like they are in
a different place in their life and have
a better base of knowledge than a nine
year old or a 10 year old but does that
play into it as well or do you think
that literally is just a different way
of teaching that actually gets different
results well I had no idea how this
course was gonna be structured when I
when I decided to enroll like I just
thought I was gonna learn how to write
for modern times I had all this ideas
about education that I wanted to put out
there and I was like sure I want to take
this I was expecting a passing Chronos I
think that's how you pronounce it kind
of course where you know they just
upload different videos you have to go
through the modules and there's like a
forum and this and that like that's what
I was expecting
and then I was like after the first
session I was like whoa I need to think
of a way to bring this to kids and
that's exactly what I emailed David that
day I was like this was incredible like
I cannot believe the interactions how I
was put into breakout groups with
different people and I actually felt
like we were in real person talking and
then you know he uses the flipped
classroom approach which is that the
videos or the lecture you watch a video
in the afternoon or at any time that you
can and then when you show up to class
then you're just discussing what you
learned you're you come in with your
writing you get feedback you get to
socialize and that's the way that we
should be structuring this kind of thing
that's really dynamic so that's kind of
when I tried to replicate with our
summer camp that's what we called it we
started with a pilot just cuz we're
testing all this ideas to see how I
would
the kids and I have for a week a group
of kids that were nine through 11 and
they would join this virtual space and I
kind of try to emulate that same
structure that they were using and it
worked beautifully like it was insane
how the kids were totally engaged at
first they were a little skeptical that
I wasn't telling them what to do but by
the second day they were doing you know
they were all engaged working they had
like the chat they were throwing in the
comments we would put them in breakout
groups and they were like giving each
other feedback like it just you know it
was incredible what they accomplished
and this is not the kind of engagement
that you see in online remote learning
that's going on in schools right now and
and I really think that I mean it works
it works for kids the one component that
I haven't been able to figure out is
that the courses that they teach to
adults they can be you know massive like
you can have 150 people to 500 people in
a course and people are engaged because
they're adults with kids I am not so
sure I had 12 kids in my pilot right and
I'm just still trying to figure out
because I I do feel like they need that
one-on-one and and that personalized
attention so I'm still trying to figure
out that component but it works like
that method I saw that it works how can
adults can't like capitalize on this
right meaning that there's a lot of
people that are listening who say hey
this is already for my kid but like I'm
still interested in learning myself how
can they continue to learn as they get
older given that they grew up in a
system that you believe in I'd tend to
agree with you can and will be changed
but for adults to kind of continue to
learn how do they do
yeah well first they need to be open to
this idea of unlearning much of what
they learned in school
for example this course right of passage
that I took with David basically made me
on learn the way that I learned to write
and the way that I talked to my kids to
write in school which was painful for
kids and for me as I was following the
curriculum when I entered this class it
was like a completely different approach
like like completely different grabbing
what they taught you in school do the
opposite so and it helped me and hey I
am publishing I am writing I started
voicing my thoughts and it opened my
eyes to this idea of being a citizen of
the Internet and having access to all
this people and this idea so my best
advice is for and I kind of want to get
kids into this but I'm still trying to
figure out the logistics in the security
component but to become citizen of the
Internet just become an you know have
your online persona and start finding
the courses that you find interesting
and then writing about these things and
putting your thoughts out there or
making videos or but I really believe in
this idea of publishing you know like by
publishing you you get to meet other
people you get to put your ideas out
there connect with like-minded people
and and organize your ideas and you keep
learning like I'm addicted to learning
at this point because I just keep
finding things as I am writing and
posting and reading so I think the best
way is to use the Internet and leverage
the internet right now and and find
those communities of online people that
are forming that I I didn't really
believe in before but now I really do
because I've seen how they work so one
thing she mentioned is like you took the
course where there was kind of the
exchange of information and now you're
putting it into practice right you're
creating your writing you're doing all
this kind of stuff and it feels like
that's a common thread whether it's a
nine-year-old kid yourself right or
somebody who's 60 years old and still
wants to learn is this creation piece of
it so how do you feel like that fits in
on the online learning side um you mean
like how do you learn like rephrase that
question like how do you learn so like
if you're a young kid or your
six-year-old right there's this whole
idea if I can go online I can read all
this stuff but then I've got actually go
and the creation part is a
part of the actual learning itself and
so how does that fit into just consuming
information on the Internet oh oh yeah
absolutely so so that's a big thing
because now with all this you know
information accessible anyone you can
you can you can actually fall into the
rabbit hole just consume consume consume
but a big part of it is producing things
and there's so many ways to be a
producer nowadays you know like you can
do videos you can do podcasts you can be
a designer you can write about it so
what I've been trying to incentivize the
kids that I'm working with is well what
do you like to do like are you really
passionate about taking photos like a
photographer you know photography are
you really passionate about writing are
you really passionate about you know
talking and and based on their interest
then figure out how they can you know
produce and and and put their thoughts
out there in whatever medium that they
like and with computers it's really you
know it's it's become a lot easier so
really getting and adults can try this
too like what's the medium that you like
like when I you I started with writing
which is still really challenging for me
but then I started to try video and it
turns out that I really like doing
videos so exploring and putting yourself
out there and encouraging you the kids
to do the same thing until you find
what's the best way that works for you
to share all the things that you're
consuming I have to imagine that kids
especially when you ask them what do you
like to do there's some form of social
media that is the answer
and then when you ask them what do you
want to be when you grow up I'm assuming
that maybe not 9 in 10 a little bit
older you start to get the like I want
to be an Instagram influencer or tick
tock star or whatever how do you kind of
still help kids that it doesn't look
like to probably most adults it's like
that's a job opportunity or a path to
pursue in life I think you me and many
others I was like no actually those
people are doing quite well for
themselves it's so kinda like how do you
deal with kids who want to pursue things
that are just like more soft skill based
and and more kind of content related
more so than like hey I want to go and
do something like a software engineer or
something like that
my answer is go for it to me and this is
something that you know for example my
husband he were very different and he's
like what do you
when we talk about you know when we have
kids how are we gonna raise their kids
and this and I'm always like whatever
they tell us that they're interested in
we're gonna drop everything we're doing
and we're just gonna say yes you want to
learn about that let's go ahead and
nurture that because here's what I've
noticed like if a kid is really
interested in something let's say
becoming a YouTube star or becoming
something and you encourage that
obviously we're talking about things
that are good for them right but if they
say that they're interested in something
like no but so if you Inc if you support
them and you encourage that and you're
there like it's not like you're gonna
just drop them you're they're kind of
like observing and being a guide but you
support their motion and you give them
the resources you will be surprised with
the things they can accomplish and that
is one of the big things that's lacking
in schools that kids we we don't part
from the kids interest and for example
if the kid is telling you like oh I want
to learn about government and you're
like no no we're gonna learn about the
Middle Ages because government you're
gonna learning eighth grade it's like
wait what no if the kid is telling you
that they want to learn about something
and they want to do something you need
to take advantage of that because that
really happens so whatever they say that
they want to pursue you you help them
and then you you're there as a guide to
show them what's the best way to do it
and and make sure that they are you know
doing something productive but you go
for that like I I am a firm believer
that it doesn't matter if you want to
you know create Lego blocks or be you
know scientists or whatever it take
photographs whatever it is that you want
to do you should be able to try it out
right and and and kids are very excited
when they try things out so give them
the chance to do it when I hear you talk
it sounds very similar too rather than
in the old model where teachers there is
no kind of option as to how else you can
learn the teacher is going to give you
the information in this format and like
it's all about what you learn really
what it sounds like you're talking about
is that evolution of the teachers role
or more of a facilitator and actually
showing the kids how to write it's
teaching them here's how you use the
computer here's how you actually go and
do research and all that kind of stuff
and the what is almost less important
than how is that fair you you absolutely
nailed it that's exactly right
and the problem is that you know many
many parents are scared to to kind of
like
they don't really know how to manage
this whole like kids using the
technology and wanting to do research
but the thing is like I'm like the
parents have way more experience of the
kids so instead of being like the enemy
or prohibiting them from doing they're
gonna do it anyway so be an ally like
sit next to them and be like oh you
don't know how to research like which
let me show you the right way to
research let me show you why you know
when kids ask me like Miss Bob why do
teachers hate Wikipedia so much like
what's so bad about Wikipedia I'm like
there's nothing wrong about Wikipedia
like the thing about Wikipedia is that
sometimes people will post things that
are not correct but hey let's try it out
so you you don't you don't just like
disregard what they're saying you teach
them how to use the platform correctly
you teach them how do you do research
you teach them how to use Wikipedia like
you wanna you just wrote an article
about global warming you want to add it
to the Wikipedia page that talks about
global warming let's go ahead and do it
if they put it down let's see why they
put it down like that's a learning
opportunity you know so it's you know
and catering curt they're motivated cuz
they're like I can contribute to the
body of knowledge that's out there that
anyone can read like what's more
motivating than that so instead of
saying no and and like help them with
their curiosities help them do their you
know teach them how to do the research
and and because we want they do need
help in order to do things well right
but but we're not really giving that
help right now so I feel like that's
really important to kind of like walk
them through the things that they're
already exploring what are the
technologies that you think help
facilitate all this obviously we're
doing this on zoom' I'm assuming zoom is
a big piece of a lot of it but we're
some of the other technologies or
platforms that you feel like are gonna
play a big role and helping all this
online learning so at this point I've
wanted to keep it very simple because um
I I realized that we Lee again the
online like the online space is just for
interactions to share what you've
created to socialize and get feedback
right so to me that's the main purpose
so zoom works really well like this
video conferencing I feel like a lot of
the rest of the learning gets done
outside you know of the interactions
here but I haven't explored that many
software's the things that I if I had
kids right now I would get them a Mac
and I would be like okay this comes with
iMovie go ahead and explore this week
explore iMovie you know you get to make
trailers you get to make movies and then
learn
edit and you can learn how to edit by
going on YouTube and figuring out with a
computer with the Mac you also get like
a GarageBand
go ahead and explore like you can create
your own music you can write you know
make a podcast like try that out with
that you also get all this design things
where you can try like if the kid likes
to design like all these things you get
from just a computer like you want to
try blogging short let's go ahead and
try blogging so to me it's not really
about like software's out there like I
haven't been trying that many I don't
feel like it's a syrette limit I think
it's just kind of like using the
applications that you have accessible to
create the whole point is just to be
making things and putting them out there
what do you think are the risks of kind
of changing the way that kids are
learning we've talked about a lot of the
positives and you and I think are pretty
convinced that like this is a good
direction to head in but what are the
risks or the downsides to pursuing this
type of Education
you mean like the alternatives right so
I'm not gonna have a lot to say here
because every time I think of something
negative I'll do my research and I'm
like ha I found a way to figure this out
so that's not a problem anymore but many
parents are like okay like I buy into it
I kind of want to try it out but what if
you know I realize later on that I do
want to kid what want to put my kid into
school or that I do want for my kid to
go to college you know and and like what
am I gonna do well here's what I
realized with kids that for example go
to Montessori elementary schools and
then elementary school ends and then
that kid has to transition to a more
traditional school it is true that you
will see a little bit of I mean it's
it's different right the kid is used to
learning in their own way unstructured
like you know follow their interest and
suddenly like they transition to a place
where they're telling you what to do
they're telling you what to learn
they're telling you how to learn that
and how to show that you learn that
obviously you will see like a little
bump there and some parents get
discouraged and they see that as Oh
Montessori schools did not prepare my
kids well and no it's just that you're
putting them back into it's true
structure that is really challenging to
learning so I mean that's one of the
things that I see like if you start off
with like let's say an online learning
experience and then you try to put your
kid into traditional school you may
notice that so that's one thing and then
the other thing that they're like well
what if I want for my kid to go to
college right like and and I've pursued
this
alternative path and I I did my research
and colleges actually are you know they
accept homeschooled kids they accept
kids that have done some other forms of
education I'm assuming that you do have
to show some kind of like progress or
but I do know that that on schoolers I
don't have you've heard of that term
like the unschoolers so yeah you have
like word schooling and homeschooling
and unschoolers so um unschooling is
basically like you don't have a
curriculum and your homeschool but it's
just what the kid decides right so it's
very like the extreme the other extreme
but even on schoolers can getting to
college if they want to so those are the
two things that I see how those could be
like little bumps um and then also if a
kid is home and doesn't have the support
of a parent to be kind of like they're
facilitating the experience and you
don't have to be 100% involved but kind
of like they're then I do see that as
challenging right some parents like
really have to go to work and have to
deposit their kids somewhere which is
kind of the function of schools and for
that I that's also kind of like an issue
with this kind of like alternative
educational experiences yeah and it
feels like I've got a couple of friends
who that they're definitely feeling the
pain of that right now or they're like
oh man this like dealing with a
six-year-old all day is like really
tough and kind of this idea of like hey
the teacher is actually the one taking
care of them for some period of time and
I guess the other piece of it too then
is like if you think it from like a
socioeconomic status standpoint right
people who were service jobs the kind of
lower socioeconomic status or the ones
that are more likely to need the child
care that school provides because both
parents are working both parents are
going to to to a job and stuff like that
yeah one of my favorite forms of a like
alternative education is something
called micro schools have you heard of
micro schools they're becoming too you
know they're becoming more popular
nowadays and I really think that this is
kind of like the model of Education that
has a lot of potential to take off so
microscope are a form of home schooling
that's done by one parent or one
educator in different neighborhoods so
let's say that we live close by and I
say I'm a teacher and I want to teach so
I open a micro
school in my house and it's like five to
six kids and your kid comes over and the
other neighbor comes over and then we
create a curriculum and it can be either
so it's kind of like a homeschooling but
with more kids and facilitated by one
person right like either a teacher or a
parent that has the time and wants to do
it and what I love about this is that
you can either do it your way like you
create your own curriculum based on the
needs of the community you know if it's
like a Spanish community you can add
Spanish in the curriculum and so on and
so forth
and it's in a very nurturing space
because it's at a home and you have you
know you're not by yourself in home
school you have other kids that you're
interacting with but also like they're
this company's like I know there's like
wonder schools and there's prenda learn
and there are a few others that they're
micro school centers that they help you
set this up and they provide the
resources in case a parent or a teacher
wants more guidance right and I feel
like this and the price obviously is
nothing compared to an elementary school
I feel like this way is a way more
organic way for kids to learn it gives
parents the ability to be able to go
back to work and knowing that your kid
is at a safe place
with someone in your neighborhood and
and it's you know kids are more engaged
because it's only a few hours and
they're doing things that they find
exciting it's a lot more personalized so
this trend is growing and and I feel
like it's easy to replicate in anywhere
right you just need a whole loom
someone willing to do it and then either
you do it on your own or you ask for the
resources from this company so I feel
like that is probably more sustainable
than let's say homeschooling
for parents that cannot afford you know
to stay home or yeah that makes a lot of
sense actually it sounds pretty cool as
we go to wrap up what is your one piece
of advice for parents that are looking
at kind of these alternative ways of
learning for their kids
yeah so to me the whole point why I'm
doing all this is because I feel like a
lot of these things people kind of have
in the back of their mind because we've
all been through some form of schooling
and we've all experienced all these
things um but unless we bring them up
people don't quite think about them a
lot of parents don't think about them
but when we do bring them up and this is
the feedback I've been getting from
people who read my content is that it
starts to kind of light up something
right and you start to think about your
child's education in a new way and even
if you cannot pull your kid out of the
traditional school system which is very
likely that many parents are not gonna
be able to you can at least start to
wait the learning that happens outside
of school even more than the learning
that's going inside school right you can
start looking at the grade and knowing
like oh this doesn't really mean that my
kid is learning you can start using the
time after school to create you know
maybe some learning experience where
they can you know work on their creative
side if your kid tells you that they're
interested or ask your kid what is what
what are you interested in let's explore
that you know kind of like like explore
this creative side of kids because if
you've heard this conversation you
already know that that schools
unfortunately are not digging into that
they're not digging into kids creative
side they're not digging into kids
interests so try to find a way to
compensate for that when they come back
home right or you know try to find
alternative maybe online experiences
where kids can have like that
complimentary side and nourish that side
so hopefully like that's something that
people who listen to this are going to
start considering I asked the same two
questions to end each episode that you
get ask me one to finish up but the
first one is what is the most important
book that you've ever read well that's a
challenging one so probably the war on
art have you heard that book by Steven
Pressfield it just talks about
resistance and and I feel like this is
something that I came into it you know
thinking of students and how I could
help them you know kind of battle this
resistance that they have every day in
order to raise their hand because we've
conditioned them not to and to save
things that come through their mind and
then I ended up just learning a lot of
things myself from the book and and I
you know it's kind of like those books
that I just revisit all the time and I
bought multiple copies and give it to my
friends so so that book is just really
really good
I could I could mention more but anyway
doing more on art yeah all right the art
of war wait let me I'll tell you in a
second let me just check okay
the art of war I think is some zoo is a
different book she quickly she's quickly
googling da what's the war of art the
war of arts okay God
second question more fun one aliens
believer or non-believer on aliens yes
my husband's gonna be like what I do not
I do not he's me I do not believe in
aliens why I just don't I just don't I
feel like if there were aliens they
would have already kind of like invaded
or done something about it
I do not know they're here um no no I
mean if there are aliens are probably
like what in the world like like what's
going on right now like oh this is
happening because of the bat everyone
still go like that I do think often like
if they're probably like oh my god this
humans but what your husband believes in
you don't well he's been kind of you
know sensing giving me the sense that he
does that there are a few things that
point out and I'm like I don't even want
to engage like absolutely what I can
tell you do believe in them because of
your reaction it to me it's a
mathematical thing right it's just like
the world is so bit or the the galaxy
and kind of the space everything is so
big and expansive that like the
probability is that there's aliens the
big question is are we here at the exact
same time they are in terms of you know
let's say humans we've got a nice couple
million of year run existing on earth
like are aliens here or did they come
before us after us who knows but there's
gotta be intelligent life somewhere ok
wait that's a different question yes I
do feel like there other living
creatures out there I just wouldn't
categorize them as aliens but for sure
for sure I do feel like their other
living things out there yeah alright
you're forgiven you
forgiving you could ask me one question
to finish that what do you got for me oh
okay only one let's see um what do you
think that kids should be learning
nowadays like what's something that you
did learning school that you're like I I
think kids should be learning this
instead of all the other stuff
there's two things and there's somewhat
related
no not Bitcoin actually personal finance
though for sure I feel like a lot of the
societal issues that we have are built
on the premise that 50% or more of the
population doesn't understand how money
works how the financial industry works
simple things like why you should pay
off your credit card at the end of every
month right that isn't so much like this
is gonna change society but like it will
have a material impact on kids
specifically also the damage of taking
on hundreds of thousands of dollars of
debt to go to college and like very
simple things that once you understand
them you're like oh that makes sense but
we just don't really educate people on
and the second thing is I do think that
we should do a better job of like
teaching entrepreneurship and with the
idea being kind of somewhere when you're
talking about like the creation and all
that but it's you learned so many things
other than just business right you
learned leadership and how to manage
people and interact with people in the
business so that you learn negotiation
you understand marketing operations or
like all of these different aspects that
go into trying to build a company or
like a product that it doesn't matter if
you end up actually wanting to own
businesses when you get older or you go
and you work at a business like you will
be a better employee because of it and
you will also be a better business owner
because of it and so it just feels like
it's like one of those well-rounded
skills that exposes somebody very
quickly to a lot of different aspects of
of kind of the world and so you know
well I think we're like why would you
force kids to start businesses and
really business so like startup business
as much as it's like what do you want to
build right I think your your point of
like being a creator I definitely agree
has a lot of positive impact to it
Austin well I'll make sure to include
something like that in my future school
so when you have to bring them over
awesome where where can people
find you on the internet and where do
you want to send them any web pages or
places where you're writing or anything
yeah so I have my personal website it's
Anna Lorena fabrica calm that's where I
write you know I have a blog there I
send a weekly newsletter which you can
also subscribe there and the link is a
fabrica calm
it's called top Friday's it goes out
every Friday on childhood education but
really I covered like education overall
um I recently started a YouTube channel
with some of the tips that you gave the
other day in the conversation with David
fell and and I'm very active on Twitter
so so yeah those are the places where
you can find me what's your Twitter
username for people yeah Anna sbrega
eleven what where I got asked eleven
what's the eleven for my birthday's
February 11 and I was like my name is
Anna my sister's name is Anna and my
mom's name is Anna so we're all on of
iboga so I just added at the 11 so it
could be weird I love that I love that I
feel like Twitter names with numbers in
them always have some kind of meeting
right so but you got to ask what the
with the numbers for absolutely
absolutely yeah just my birthday
February 11th awesome alright well thank
you so much for doing this I think we're
gonna learn a ton and let's do together
the future palm thank you for having me
this is a great conversation